is consuming yogurt the best way to get
your probiotics
well the answer is
no it's not unfortunately the bacteria
and yogurt gets killed at the stomach
level not to mention there's limited
strains of microbes in yogurt i mean
sometimes there's two sometimes there's
three
if you're lucky you might have five or
six and the way that they
rate these microbes
is by a unit called c f
u and that stands for colony forming
units so yogurt usually has about i
don't know 3.6
cfus but here's the problem most yogurt
out there is pasteurized and these
microbes do not survive
heat so basically you're consuming dead
bacteria not to mention the extra
lactose which
so many people have lactose intolerance
so they have digestive issues from that
not to mention casein allergies it's the
protein in milk many people are
sensitive to that as well and we won't
even talk about the added amount of
sugar that they put in yogurt now i am
speaking generally there are certain
yogurts out there that are way better
than others
like the bulgarian yogurt right that's
an awesome product but the conventional
yogurts are not going to give you the
probiotics that you really
need
now what about kefir okay well kefir is
very different than yogurt the way they
make kefir is with a kefir grain which
are different strains of microorganisms
which includes friendly yeast but the
word kefir is a turkish word that means
feel good after a meal and this is
probably why people like consuming
probiotics because it just makes their
stomach feel better and what goes on
with your digestive system has a huge
influence on what's going on up here
you're going to feel better in your head
if things are better in your stomach now
kefir compared to yogurt has like nine
times the cfus it has like 27 billion
cfus as compared to like 3.6 billion for
yogurt and the lactose the milk sugar is
almost non-existent because
the lactic acid bacteria eat up
this lactose milk sugar and so if you
are lactose intolerant you'll have much
less of a problem and so you have more
friendly bacteria and you have a lot of
different diversity you have many
different types of strains that are very
beneficial to your gut so kefir is a
much better option but obviously make
sure you just get the plain one not the
one with added sugar and i would make
sure that it's organic and from cows
that are grass-fed or even
sheep or goats that are grass-fed but
kefir is a really good one to get your
probiotics
now what about sauerkraut well
sauerkraut is not a fermented
dairy product you're fermenting
cabbage and even though per serving size
sauerkraut only has like three
billion cfus the juice from the
sauerkraut
per tablespoon has like 10 billion cfus
and if you're gonna consume sauerkraut
you usually have more than one
tablespoon and so you can have a lot
more friendly bacteria when you have
sauerkraut
make sure when you get sauerkraut that
it's not pasteurized okay because the
heat kills the microbes but sauerkraut
also has the probiotic it has the fiber
that feeds your microbes that help with
other ways like blood sugars it's loaded
with vitamin k1 vitamin k2 which is very
unique because vitamin k2 helps
transport calcium
out of the wrong places in your body so
it gets it out of the soft tissue and it
puts it back in the bone it also has a
lot of potassium and even some really
cool phytonutrients like lutein
and zeaxanthin
which are really good for your eyes and
another unique thing about sauerkraut is
the vitamin u okay now you might say
well i've never heard vitamin u well
vitamin u is good for everything
digestion
all sorts of digestive problems from
diverticulitis to irritable bowel
syndrome to bloating to ulcers
anything inflammation in your gut
vitamin u can help and that leads me to
the next cabbage fermentation product
kimchi now kimchi is a powerhouse when
you're talking about superfoods
it's fermented cabbage with red chili
sometimes they put radish in there which
is a superfood radishes are fascinating
because they
have a very potent anti-cancer effects
they're really good for extracting deep
mucus inside your body
fantastic for the liver and they are a
cruciferous now kimchi also has garlic
which is by itself one of the
best things for viral infections and and
so many other health benefits then you
have ginger okay which is another
superfood good for your digestion
and sea salt now there's many other
things i'll put in kimchi but
it's a superfood
it's also really good for
sinus infections i've done a video on
that i will put that link down below
one serving size like one cup will give
you about five
billion cfus but the juice from kimchi
probably is equivalent if not more
to the sauerkraut juice now kimchi has
some very unique microorganisms that are
different from other fermented products
especially in the area of lactic acid
bacteria and so they can create
different effects kimchi is super high
in vitamin c just like sauerkraut super
high in k1 vitamin k2 as well as
potassium and b vitamins now relating to
pickles okay i want to just mention
something about pickles there's two
different ways they make pickles one is
through vinegar which actually is is
pretty good but the lacto-fermented
pickles are much better because they're
going to give you the probiotics that
are going to help you just make sure
they're unpasteurized they're not
cooked and you have to keep them in the
refrigerator or root cellar to preserve
them now if you haven't seen my video on
kimchi
i think you should watch it it's pretty
interesting check it out i put it right
here
you